en 2007 edf démarre la construction des
réacteurs 3 2 le père de flamanville il
devrait être fini en 2012
sauf que sept ans plus tard le chantier
s'éternise il devait coûter 3,3
milliards d'euros
il en coûtera finalement plus de 11 tout
le monde se doute un peu qui va avoir un
petit peu de retard mais de là à accuser
un retard de presque 10 ans une facture
multipliée par trois les bordes ont été
un peu dépassé le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que le retour d'expérience
sur la construction et le fonctionnement
de ce de cette paire de flamanville est
pour le moment
évidemment extrêmement négatif
pour comprendre pourquoi il est un
problème avec le père de flamanville il
faut revenir un peu en arrière nous
sommes en 1986 quand la catastrophe de
tchernobyl se produit les autorités
françaises veulent construire des
centrales nucléaires plus sûr et un ep
air apporte des garanties en termes de
sécurité que ne possède pas une centrale
classique
le p r c'est un réacteur qui dès le
départ se voulait plus robuste avec plus
de redondance des systèmes de sauvegarde
et c'est donc un réacteur dont
l'objectif principal était de réduire le
risque d'accidents graves ou d'accident
majeur
le père est jugé plus sûr il est plus
rocard la mode est au réacteur plus
puissant pour produire plus d'énergie
ainsi il permet de compenser les frais
de sa fabrication qui est plus coûteuse
la construction démarre en 2007
et très vite les premiers retards sont
évoqués ce que edf n'a plus construit
aucun réacteur nucléaire depuis 25 ans
donc il faut renouveler tout un arsenal
de compétences on apprend en même temps
qu'on fait donc ceci entraîne un retard
très important d'autant qu'en mars 2011
la donne change pour le nucléaire
un tsunami se produit au japon et
provoque la catastrophe de fukushima
l'asn l' agence de sûreté nucléaire va
alors se montrer plus intransigeante que
jamais dans ses contrôles ses
inspections sont à l'origine de nouveaux
travaux et donc de nouveaux retards en
l'occurrence les soudures les
équipements les enceintes où ça a été
passé au peigne fin et certains
équipements ont dû être refaits
en 2015 l'asn publié un rapport alarmant
l'agencé estime que la cuve la baignoire
en acier dans lequel se trouve le
réacteur est défectueuse sa trop grande
teneur en carbone la rendre et trop peu
sur finalement edf a effectué plusieurs
tests et obtenir gain de cause
mais plusieurs mois auront passé
l'autorité de sûreté a finalement jugé
que les marges bien qu'ils t'ont réduite
par rapport à ce qui était initialement
prévu restait suffisante et que donc on
pouvait conserver cette cuve en état et
en 2018 l'asm pointe un nouveau problème
celui des soudures ce sont des soudures
évidemment plus importantes que celles
qu'on trouve chez soi il ya donc 8
soudure laurent l'asn a dit qu'elle
devrait être refaite
le problème c'est que ces huit soudure
importantes sont à l'intérieur du
réacteur
autrement dit s'il faut refaire ses
soudures il faut détruire cette enceinte
du réacteur pour refaire des soudures ce
qui entraîne un retard considérable pour
le chantier ça peut être deux trois
quatre cinq ou six ans il ya une erreur
disons de conception initiale aussi dans
le fait de mettre des soudures un
endroit aussi peu accessible avec un tel
enjeu de qualité sans prévoir de pouvoir
les réparer
aujourd'hui deux thèses s'affrontent
d'un côté edf qui assure que les
standards de sécurité sont suffisants
pour lancer son notaire ce que dit le
dfc que ses soudures présente malgré
tout des garanties de sécurité
suffisantes qu'on peut donc faire
démarrer le réacteur et qu'on profitera
du premier arrêt décennal pour les
refaire et de l'autre les experts de
l'asn qui disent qu'il faut tout refaire
sur ce problème de soudure on a depuis
la conception la contractualisation la
surveillance de chantier là la conduite
globale et la conception du chantier par
rapport aux risques et jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui aux actions correctives une
succession absolument incroyable de
défaillance à toutes les étapes de la
gestion
tous ces retards accumulés sont un grand
coup porté à la stratégie d'edf
le p r de flamanville devait être une
vitrine à l'international pour le
nucléaire français à l'époque dans les
années 2000 la france rêvait d'exporter
des dizaines de ce réacteur dans le
monde
la démonstration que fait
malheureusement edf de son incapacité à
maîtriser le chantier de flamanville
réduit encore les perspectives de
d'exportation de réacteurs français
et alors qu edf était précurseur dans la
construction 2 p r en france et dans le
monde c'est en chine en 2019 que le
premier réacteur de ce type voient le
jour
les besoins en énergie de la chine sont
telles qu'il a fallu certainement
accélérer cette p r il faut rappeler
également que edf à son maximum à 1000
3000 personnes sur le chantier
là où les chinois en mettre 10 milles 12
mille ou plus il n'empêche que la
technologie en france
la chine est la même et qu'un certain
nombre de la chaîne yeux relief ont été
amenés à travailler en chine sur le p r
[Musique]
et si le père de flamanville ne voyait
finalement jamais le jour
c'est ce que demandent plusieurs
associations écologistes
mais edf ne veut pas en entendre parler
comment se résoudre à abandonner un
projet qui a coûté plus de 10 milliards
d'euros
il est sûr qu'il ne te plaire est
aujourd'hui une incertitude extrême mais
qui pèse sur l'avenir d'edf s'est d'ores
et déjà un accident industriel
mais si cette p r parvient un jour à
fonctionner et qui fonctionne pendant 60
70 ans
on oubliera peut-être assez rapidement
que la facture s'est envolé de voilà a
été multiplié par trois et que le
chantier est arrivé avec 10 ou plus en
de retard c'est vraiment le problème de
ce genre de projet c'est il ya un mot
anglais qui décrit très bien ça c'est le
hunt chapman c'est à dire que on est
piégé dans un projet tellement lourd et
dans lequel on a tellement
me d'efforts d'investissement que
l'abandon
ne peut plus être considéré qu'une
option comme une option alors même que
l'acharnement la poursuite du chantier
va coûter de plus en plus cher et qu'à
un moment donné on peut effectivement se
poser la question
il est évident que si l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire dit il faut refaire les
soudures et qu'on s'aperçoit que ça va
prendre 5 7 8 ans supplémentaires
la question va se poser en même temps
est-ce que dfs que l'industrie française
peut prendre le risque d'abandonner un
chantier dans lequel on a investi 11
milliards d'euros
ça me semble problématique surtout que
pour le moment edf n'a aucun autre outil
pour remplacer les centrales actuelles
c'est le p r et uniquement le p r qui
incarne le renouveau des centrales
nucléaires en france
[Musique]